[Musique]
masques singers et le nouveau gros show
de tf1
si la première avait cartonné avec plus
de 6.5 millions de téléspectateurs
le deuxième épisode a déjà perdu plus
d'un million de fidèles l'une des
raisons pourrait être le casting de
l'émission qui se dévoile petit à petit
les enquêteurs essayent tant bien que
mal de nous faire croire qu'il y a de
grosses stars derrière les masques ce
n'est pas lady gaga non ça n'est pas
lady gaga c'est plutôt marie josé pérec
et sheila alors devons-nous continuer à
chercher des grandes stars sous ses
déguisements terrifiante où tout est
possible
ce casting fait en tout cas beaucoup
réagir à pierre-jean chalencon
d'affaires conclues a même déclaré sur
le plateau de jean marc morandini c'est
des gens qui sort en fin de parcours
aussi entre guillemets sans être méchant
et qui veulent revenir sur le devant de
la scène et il ferait n'importe quoi
pour revenir sur le devant de la scène
le casting du show n'a pas encore
dévoilé toutes ses vérités mais selon
les dernières rumeurs il n'y aurait pas
beaucoup de grands noms cachés sous les
masques
alors selon vous le casting de masques
singer n'est-il pas en train de tuer
l'émission c'est là pour le coup c'est
un c'est un non c'est pas forcément un
nom qui parle qu'aux plus jeunes mais
c'est un vrai patron télévision ce qu'on
avait envie de voir c'est déjà rare en
télévision non mais c'est ça enfin qui
est on pour dire s'ils ne sont pas des
grandes stars marie josé pérec est une
grande star dans le monde du sport
sheila est une grande star aussi moi je
pense que c'est pas le casting qui fait
du mal à l'émission c'est l'émission en
elle même
honnêtement on vous l'avait dit les 4-14
ans non ma fille me faire regarder
l'émission pourquoi pour les peluches
quand on avait dit sur ce plateau que
les peluches c'était le spectacle de
chantal goya version 2.0 moi je le
réitère je redis ce que j'avais dit pour
moi c'est ça je regarde un spectacle de
chantal goya qui était super il ya 20
ans mais là moi ça ne m'amuse pas alors
évidemment ça me donne tort parce que
les scores sont très bons mais moi pour
moi ça ne peut pas coller les décors
sont très bons mais attendez ce message
est ben voila mais ça va continuer à
baisser nos concepts des bidons des gens
qui chantent mais c'est pas du direct
donc ils font semblant de bouger dans
des dents des dans des costumes
résultats ou ces petits vidéos ne
l'appliquent pas de ces concepts et
vidéos prix de s'exprimer il a fait le
succès en amérique il n'y a pas d'emploi
des brestois s'est juré excusez-moi par
le rire le jury par d'un il est plus
tard il est plus tard que les candidats
oui parce que anggun c'est une star
internationale est allé franchement
c'est vraiment charrie l'extraordinaire
cavada mme chan parle même pas et et
subit aussi l'accord avec magna
on affiche effectivement victoria
semaine dernière je sais pourquoi tu
regardes parce qu'elle m'a engueulé
parce que j'ai balancé le nom de qui
était derrière la licorne est très mal
d'avoir fait ça mais tel que nous révèle
t il que nous révèle le catlin on va pas
tarder ça te regarde et maman parce
qu'effectivement les déguisements c'est
trop jolie je mette la licorne
donc c'est trop mignon mais c'est vrai
que ça peut on n'a pas besoin d'avoir
des marie josé pérec part il ya deux
choses
avant de parler du casting c'est la
mécanique de l'émission qui est
répétitive ça c'est sûr et ensuite c'est
vrai que bon le truc des costumes des
peluches salaces mais c'est vrai que
votre question elle est très pertinent à
jour merci le le casting il a il est pas
en train ils tuent l'émission parce que
une inadéquation totale entre les noms
qui sortent des peluches et la tante des
jeunes on les connaît pas il faut
ajouter à ça que tout est connue serre
que le jury fait semblant de
s'émerveiller
en fait tout est sorti donc c'est hyper
déceptif ça a marché une fois avec un
effet de surprise
ça ne va faire que dégringoler il y aura
pas de saison dessus ayora non mais on
n'aura pas y en aurait une parce que ça
a marché mais ce sera une catastrophe
annoncée
justin nicole vallet qu est ce que vous
auriez acheté ce programme si vous aviez
été bien trop de bruit parce qu'il est
mauvais
et sans faire le fayot paraît trop
gênant gilles verdez dans un truc mais
sans faire le fayot l'inventeur de cette
émission quand même faut le rappeler
c'est cyril hanouna avec l'âme dans la
chouette et ben oui on débat on april à
perdre pour nous là-bas à la base
c'était quand même une chanteuse déguisé
en chouette
oui oui et oui j'ai juste un truc à dire
depuis une quinzaine d'années en fait
les artistes ils viennent uniquement
faire leur promotion
vous n'auriez plus avoir d'aidé des
vraies stars qui viennent jouer le jeu
comme ça pour une émission pour un
événement est ce que je l'aurais fait
non parce que voyez bien le jury c'est
poussif
c'est à dire que même n'y croit pas ça
on sent bien que ils incarnent eux rien
qui croient pas ils y croient pas à la
blague
donc il faut surprendre dans ce genre
d'émission donc la promesse est très
très forte parce qu'elle est vraiment
forte
elle est belle la promesse mais derrière
ces ultras déceptif donc la première l'a
montré un score très très haut
perdre un million de téléspectateurs en
une semaine c'est énorme quand elle veut
dire qu'on peut encore perdre environ un
million alors quatre émissions à la
diffuser alors là ils ont alors ils ont
quand même me fait un peu du tice comme
on dit dans notre jargon pour booster
les missions et ils ont passé l'extrait
de de l'aigle et écoutez bien la
prestation chantée de l'aigle et
franchement on reconnaît la personne
avec l'autre ce serait dire quoi tu veux
finir maintenant moi je le disais pour
deux clubs aux saveurs
oui j'ai balancé ce band si c'est pas
suspect n'est pas bien parce que
évidemment les internautes sur twitter
s'en donnent à coeur joie mais ça c'est
le jeu et c'est vrai qu'ils sont ils
sont où les tombées juste que sur le
lyon par exemple le laisser en écho aux
rumeurs
marc lavoine ont alors ses annexes
on a même que dans l'émission nous avons
la taille et de leur nom on a un enfant
de lui coller mais pour les cornes le
panda julie zenatti l'aigle marque la
bonne à mon avis non c'est pas marc
lavoine non l'hippocampe florence
foresti
ça m'étonnerait le monde des mallettes
jarry a dit qu'il connaissait
personnellement 90% du casting
donc on est sûr qu'il aura pas de stars
hollywoodiennes de celui-là gars comme
il l'annoncé d'une émission un maxime et
prix nobel de chimie à bâle
impossible il a à faire et d'annoncés
lady gaga mario qu'autre chose je veux
pas être celle d'aujourd'hui
cette semaine qui dit du mal de tout le
monde et peut-être un petit peu mais
est-ce qu'on peut aussi parler de devan
entre eux entre le présentateur et de
jurys qui sont quand même assez mauvaise
parce que on dit rien mais est-ce que
vous passez quand même quand vous
regardez cette émission des moments
drôles parce que moi je suis là ça n'a
pas rien parce que j'ai un train toutes
les semaines et demie vous n'êtes plus
dur c'est l'oubli qu'en fait vous n'êtes
plus dans la sécurité à l'école après
c'est vrai que le concept donc encore de
choix et qui a les quatre 4 semaines
c'est long en allemagne le beau plus tôt
vous savez que cette 6ème édition est
évidemment enregistré bref c'est un peu
dommage ç'aurait été mieux qu'ils le
fassent en direct comme le vecteur de la
maladie
c'était pas possible parce qu'il est
trop de entre les différents membres du
jury donc pour clarifier le sont entre
eux il fallait à des coupes dans le
montage des coupes dans montage dans le
monde tels accords très bien alors à
part moi alors il y aurait eu un petit
un petit couac au moment où au moins le
lion et a dû s'exprimer à ce que vous
avez comme quand tu sais qu après la
chanson leur voix est évident il est là
visiblement le mec pousser le bouton il
a oublié
regardez plus de 40 ans le mince et sur
la voix et m'a tuer qui salue
bravo leulliot déjà on voit que c'est
quelqu'un d'assez jeunes balladur ou
alors ce n'était pas comme vous pouvez
voir s'ils seront gardés mais j'ai gardé
une boîte de jeunes et il se passera
rien parle pour voir si c'est toi david
douillet vous y croyez ou pas aussi de
lyon non non pas pas dans le lion alors
roulé sur layon david thebault merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
aux conclure je suis d'audience à
prévoir ou pas avancé sur annoncé
l'émission l'émission ben oui voici je
me demandais je vous dire alors vous
pensez pour mieux cette semaine
480 mille de moins qu'en mai sylvie
moreau moi je pense qu'ils vont perdre
aussi cinq cent mille cinq cent mille
huit cent mille huit cent mille six cent
mille six cent mille à droite juste prix
500 mille cinq cent mille lieues 450 458
lisea sont ils prêts à ça le site
objectif 708 moi je vous dis france qui
a gagné elle a coûté vous avez gagné mon
éternel reconnaître